[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so thank you for having me comms is my
first time in Carlsbad no one no one
will tell me why what Carl did I I've
been really nervous all week so if you
know I'd like to find out and yeah so
thank you for taste and for having me
thank you to all our problematic
sponsors for making this event happen I
am going to do as I usually do which is
tell a story when when I was a kid I was
very good at school except for history
class it was my least favorite class I
was and still am very bad at memorizing
things that I don't see the point of
remembering like years famous men in
powder wigs are born and as a response
to my frustrations about the subject my
father would always tell me those who do
not study history are doomed to repeat
it
imagine I'm a very thick Brooklyn accent
and I resented it because it didn't make
the class any easier and my grades
improve but since then I have come to
realize that he or the Spanish
philosopher George Santayana who
actually came up with that quote I
realize that maybe he was onto something
there are many things that have happened
in history that are happening again a
lot of bad things
but also good things and we're doing a
pretty bad job at recognizing that and
adapting accordingly even in our humble
JavaScript community like have you
considered that many of our so-called
innovations in JavaScript actually have
prior art we didn't invent functional
programming or command-line interfaces
you know for JavaScript frameworks
that's like the new hot thing now we
didn't invent codes of conduct at events
every mall in Jersey in New York at
least has codes of conduct this is the
Atlantic terminal in Brooklyn and we
also did invent baking bread which is a
huge trend through here this is a really
great photo 19:17 of a couple of
backbone.js developers taking a break to
check on their their bread these
particular things have not been actively
harming society but I think it's slowing
the the industry down it's been like a
solid five years and a few months since
I entered this industry from academia
and most of the public discourse about
the language is still just shitposting
which doesn't seem very innovative or
inventive to me and I fancy myself an
innovator and an inventor I invented the
bike plow and it was at this event in
2014 when I innovated efficient search
with the jorts sort algorithm four years
later and shortswords been implemented
in 47 different languages which means
I'm not the crazy
it wasn't rxjs but then they moved repos
and I think an envious soul removed it
so maybe one of you can make a pull
request and put it back in but over the
past year or so my my focus has shifted
from jean shorts and efficient sorts to
ethics and technology especially its
relationship with art history get you a
woman who can do both
[Music]
there through my explorations of the
parallels between ethical quandaries and
the art world's past and present and the
tech industry's President future I've
learned a lot more than I anticipated
about how my decisions as a software
engineer and citizen impact the people
in the communities and I'm a part of
I think software engineers have a huge
tendency to forget that we are also
citizens and it turns out that we may
have already been doomed to repeat
history and our industry is actively
ignoring that or trying to rewrite it
and it's driven me to take a more
historical approach in my education
around web development so instead of
like just learning a cutting-edge API or
a long existing one that I finally now
have to use her project I've been
researching those technologies and I
found that it's become a requirement for
me to getting a true sense of what their
purpose is so I know exactly how to use
it a lot of people that are introduced
introduce two new frameworks or api's
they use it but they're not aware of
what the best practices are because they
don't know the history of how that
framework came to be and through that
history you kind of infer those best
practices but I wasn't invited here to
talk about how our ignoring history has
led us to normalize the existence of
Nazis in person and online or how
several the tech companies represented
here are complicit by you know actively
allowing hateful organizations like
Breitbart to sell ugly t-shirts to a
large subset of our nation that believes
that most most a few of the people in
this room don't deserve basic human
rights like actually existing or by
helping ice to organize their emails and
outlook I'm here to talk about the
tiniest unit of programmable color on a
computer-generated image enhance thank
you the pixel I'm being that this is Jas
cough which stands for JavaScript cough
I keep being reminded I should define
that pixel in JavaScript
x coordinate y coordinate and a color
but this is the amp track and so on
legally obligated to provide
high-performance JavaScript free
examples so because of the fact that
anything displayed digitally is made up
of pixels and that none of us in here
not even me can truly define what is art
I want us to move onward together on
this eight-hour filibuster so that horse
J s is not exposed with the assumption
that literally everything is pixel art
and slide transitions my name is Jen
Schiffer when I'm not shining the
spotlight on my ADHD with my bizarre
tech intros I make both pixel art and
digital art tooling specifically around
pixel art that's me
so pixel art or it's popularly searched
nickname and sometimes misnomer 8-bit
art is a style of art that embraces
retro graphics especially from
videogames going as far back as the 60s
it's a style that works both on the
screen and off my Pixar it tends to be
more analog written on paper and pixel
art is abstract you don't need to be
great or good even at drawing photo
realistic art and because it turns out
you only need a little bit of data in
this case under a thousand pixels and I
think like six colors but a little bit
of data goes a long way towards
conveying something as complex as human
emotion and that's why I make art to
express feelings and because art is
abstract enough that it provides me
means to define what perfection is when
it comes to expressing those feelings
and pixel art lowers the barrier to
artistic expression while invoking
nostalgia in a fun and positive way
which is why I love it and it's what
drives me to work on make 8-bit art calm
which is a free in browser pixel art
editor that thousands of people use
every day to express themselves in an
abstract and nostalgic way I'm also the
director of community engineering at
glich director sounds really fancy I
feel like the Greta Gerwig of JavaScript
and this is where I build and run most
of my work today and try to empower
other creative people to love and use
the web to express themselves with code
glitches the friendliest community of
coders building the apps of their dreams
and helping others to do this to do the
same glitch is similar to pixel art and
make a pit art in that I feel like it
lowers the barrier to expression while
invoking nostalgia and a fun and
positive way and then the case of glitch
the medium is code and the tools are the
community and the collaborative editor
in the browser I didn't see some glitch
users in the audience already so shouts
out and if you haven't tried it out
yourself I say give it a shot
we're trying to build something that you
know leaves people feeling joy which is
something that I feel we've seen to have
lost since the days of Geocities early
Neopets and the hit Warner Brothers film
Space Jam so I've been studying art in
tech in tandem and through that I've
become a better artist engineer and also
a better citizen I always say that to be
a good programmer you need to be using
code to do social good and not harm
which lately seems to be easier said
than done
I think that a lot of Engineers have
forgotten that or worse actively ignored
that but again I'm not here to talk
about how there are tech companies maybe
some even represented here who are paid
a lot of money to develop unsheathe
black box algorithms used to sentence
people to prison or tear families apart
there are unethical deportation
processes I'm here to talk about pig
Florida and JavaScript oh I'm sorry
so yeah
pixel art JavaScript yes because that's
what the schedule says which by the way
my page on the Jas comp website Derek
had added an Easter Egg in all the text
is in the lower case because that's how
I typically write I've always been very
interested in pixel art as someone who
creates it and as I entered the tech
industry as a proponent of the open web
and the democratization of the
she's around it I gained a passion for
creating tools to facilitate the
creation of pixel art particularly with
the JavaScript language so it makes
sense that I ended up working at glitch
so I can facilitate the creation of
JavaScript and an artistic life just
like me pixel art has a background in
academia I was a professor an
administrator and academia and then left
for the tech industry five years ago the
first time the term pixel art was
published was in the December 1982 issue
of the ACM communications journal which
ACM is the Association of Computing
Machinery are there any members in here
it's a long-running professional
organization working to advance
computing as a profession they also
author the ACM code of ethics and
professional conduct which is a must
read I wouldn't call the 1982 issue a
must read pixel art was only mentioned
to describe how they morphed the like
previous white guy president ACM into
the next white guy president of ACM I
did up on Amazon this is the least
popular book in the Animorphs series I
think that's why ACM pivoted to ethics
and professional conduct like like how
before the painting came the paint
before the pixel art there was a pixel
and someone said someone say the Picts
was created with the invention of
photography in 1839 or the first CRT
television right here in 1927 or color
television in the 1950s but they're
wrong those aren't actually pixels I
would argue that it was the
impressionist movement in the mid 1880s
where we see the first pixels
pointillism a technique popularized
popularized by Georges Seurat it's
perhaps one of the earliest forms of
analog pixel art if you can forgive the
irregular grid each dot does have a
color an x and y-coordinates on some
sort of canvas
there's a Persian by the way it would be
out of character for me to not plug my
old publication Bart Institute where I
wrote code and prose inspired by fine
artists so if you want to learn more
about Seurat and see a pic sorts been on
some of his work you should check it out
so although people are not sure exactly
when the word was for spoken pixel first
appeared in print in 1965 by the Jet
Propulsion Laboratory or JPL
surprisingly there was a time when we
were just building tech to destroy
democracy and human rights back then the
JPL was trying to enhance images from
outer space and conduct research on
computer imaging so we can have the nice
displays that we have today and in the
sixties dozens of computer scientists
working out of iconic research
institutions like JPL Xerox PARC Bell
Labs we're innovating displays and the
creation of imagery for those displays
and they were hiring artists to come and
create art with their software imagine
that allowing artists into the office
david m was one of those visual artists
he was not particularly interested in
innovating as a digital painter he came
from traditional paint but it was par
for the course when hardware and
software for making art were so young
and also like broken all the time in an
intro to his book on art cleverly titled
the art of David M he expressed exactly
how I feel about my MacBook Pro with the
touch bar he said I quickly learned that
making pictures the state of art
computers required a lot more than
simply learning user tools computer
programs are delicate and fragile as are
many of the personalities who created
them everything was in a state of
development and the machines tended to
break down speaking of display woes back
then the only way to capture digital
displays was to literally photograph the
screen I can relate as I recently moved
from using a math book to this Windows
machine and I still have no [ __ ] idea
how to take a screenshot on it
David Emmel is also one of the several
artists were able to use super paint
which is an 8-bit digital color painting
system created out of Xerox PARC by
Richard sharp and its colleagues one of
whom was the co-creator Pixar I'll be
Ray Smith if you go to his website it's
currently updated and I think rivals
space jams and this is the the rack that
the hardware sat on super paint was an
innovative image and image editing
application that became the foundation
of future imaging editing editing
software that we even used today and
this artwork black girls by this artist
Fritz Fischer who took a job as a night
guard at Xerox PARC so that he can in
his off time use the system to draw this
is one of the earliest and most
impressive digital paintings made on the
system and in 1983 super paint one Xerox
and Emmy so take that like whatever
actor ever won an Emmy well perhaps a
charm to most about super paint when I
learned about it was how its tools were
drawn using super paint itself this was
a major validation for me doing the same
for make 8-bit art calm this is actually
super paint somebody running on my
macbook you can get the executable file
and I used wine bottles so I could run
it on the Mac and it worked
look at my beautiful try so back in 2011
I was interested in learning JavaScript
and leaving academia and so I built make
a bit art comm as a way to learn
JavaScript and build something I would
use again I don't know how to explain
shot unlike super paint which sat on
like two five-foot equipment racks my
system sat on like a folder on a shared
hosting site which no an initial launch
it was a large difficult aenor that held
many smaller disk wares
where on click it would have its
background color change to one of those
several options of the color I gave the
user and to save your art I told you to
take a screenshot
maybe a horrible human what I should
have done was tell you to photograph it
to make the user experience easier
though I learned about the canvas API
realized I needed to know a little bit
more about JavaScript than just jquery's
click and CSS functions in this this
code and make a pitar is doesn't use
amps so I'm not gonna do that here you
have it you have a canvas you grab the
context depending on the X&Y of where
the mouse clicks you just draw a square
on the grid using clear rector fill
direct I was a PHP developer at the time
so the save functionality that made
sense to me was obviously to make an
AJAX call to a PHP script that created
the file I'm a shared hosting server of
the image and returned that images
location to the user for them to save
and of course I forgot to write the
script that made this files only
temporary which I realized when I got an
email from my shared hosting company
reporting that like not only was i I
disk space but like the entire like rack
was like filled with about 1,200 marques
and I realized this all could be
remedied and done client-side and so I
rewrote the whole thing and I even made
the canvas of the page the full width
the window and a new color palette
features copy/paste and I realized that
the obsolescence of my constraints as a
programmer now writing client-side
JavaScript I was through that able to
remove the constraints of the artists
using my tools including myself and if
you're interested in learning about how
I build the app with non developers in
mind you should watch my notorious
thunder planes yes talk your grandpa
probably doesn't have node
people just call it my open-source as a
prison talk as I mentioned earlier
thousands of people use make a pit art
calm to draw probably most Mario's other
than the fact that the site loads fast
as hell using jQuery and web fonts
thanks to a lot of contributors there
was nothing particularly innovative
about what's going on on the site and
remember I am an innovator and an
inventor so naturally I was driven to
explore an experiment
I got the chance to do that in 2015 do
you hear my fidgets thinner so intensity
knows offered an unpaid artist residency
at the Maidan NY Media Center live in
the life they wanted cool technologists
to show the entertainment industry that
innovative things really at a median
image Canon to happen to your city stop
move in Hollywood where are you going
and I wanted to explore how to
conceptualize map it Florida's more of a
process and path from blank canvas to
something that invokes some sort of
emotion without needing to record video
or take constant photographs in my
scream and I wanted to map that
importance of process to the work of the
everyday developer as it seems to be
what artists need to do to legitimize
their work in the tech industry still
these days at least until JPL starts
hiring more artists so here is familiar
with the joy of painting for those
you're not it features the artist Bob
Ross who paints mostly landscapes in an
instructional format aired during the
80s and 90s and I don't know about you
all who have watched it but I never
watched it solely to see the end product
I wanted to see Ross's process see how
he painted those fresh mountains and
happy trees after all the show was
called the joy of painting not the joy
of a painting and the importance of
documenting process is not only
important in art I mean who among us in
this room has not cried for joy or
terror or sadness over version control
keeping a history of our applications
code is one of the first things we set
up before we even print out hello world
these days and being able to see a
history of what code is not only it's
not only useful for reverting to before
freaking commits but it's crucial for
auditing onboarding or simply reading
the history and understanding why the
features that exist exist and why they
were written the way that they were
those who do not study history of a code
base are doomed to repeat the same
mistakes its developers made and past
sprints I said
to me the joy codon is seeing how the
developer got there like being able to
view source in history so it's not a
surprise to anyone who knows my work or
knows glitch able to view the source of
apps and it's why we brought that
functionality to server side files and
also we ever get realigned interface so
you can visually slide through the get
history of your app studying history if
we have to do it or else be doomed we
shouldn't feel doomed and cry while
we're studying it like I did in my AP
government in politics class I did not
by the way so there's been a lot of
really weird interesting debate over
whether to keep you source or get rid of
it
as if that's even a real idea it's
already kind of hidden from view and I
say it's important for new developers to
be able to learn to build the web like
we did by seeing working code and not
learning alone others say that if you
fight for view source and that means
that you hate performing code you don't
care about the people who have bad
internet access which isn't true and I
think it's a completely unfair argument
my stance on it is that it's it's 2018
we have we have a robot on Mars that
apparently sings happy birthday to
itself we have a [ __ ] Tesla orbiting
in space and you can get like a 20%
discount at Helens pizza in Jersey City
if you pay with Bitcoin so technology is
like advances [ __ ] and it's still
evolving so instead of both sides
dismissing the other's movement we
should instead figure out a way to
provide a performin information
superhighway surfing experience without
obfuscating our coach the point that
there's no transparency as to what our
apps are even doing and this can mean
that we innovate how we bundle our code
or how we host it or how browsers render
it or even what languages we build the
web in which we know is changing with
web assembly I think that's gonna be
really important with the current trend
of developers building trackers
and using people's CPUs to buy and [ __ ]
to mine cryptocurrency
and consumers are becoming more hip to
the shitty things that are being done to
them through the web and I think that if
we want the open web to win which we do
we need to throw out those straw man
arguments and just accept the fact that
we have a lot of collaborative work to
do to promote education accessibility
and performance not either/or and I
think all of us in this room and Beyond
actually do want that
but I'm not here to talk about Helens
pizza located at 183 New York Avenue in
Jersey City which if you go to my meetup
jersey script on the last Tuesday of
every month you can go down the street
and have a slice that's really a good
I'm here to talk about everyone's
favorite no no no no I'm here to talk
about process so in 2005 I found this
flash-based drawing app called otis
sketch created by adobe by a design
agency called oda pot you may know them
as the premier digital partner of
hennessey since 2012
oh no sketch was really adorable to
provide you with small newsprint like
canvas to create pastel like drawings
and the aesthetic was really cute my
favorite part was that it let you replay
the drawing of your anyone else's art so
in essence it was intentionally and
beautifully exposing the process of the
art created sadly it was a prime example
what I've been mentioning in previous
talks in line non-consensual
ephemerality as the app and its
associated gallery no longer exists
r.i.p flash this is what happens when
you allow your process and final
creation to be locked behind proprietary
services and protocols which by the way
glitch does not lock you into
proprietary languages or protocols you
can export your apps and run them
anywhere there is no to engineer scoff
exclusive I figured an auto sketch like
feature that replays the process of
drawing Pixar would be really rad for
people who draw I make a pit art to come
and it wouldn't be too hard as I'm was
already saving info about each stroke
and paint for the reduce
action allottee so basically whenever
you drew something I would save what the
X&Y coordinate and the color was and add
that to an array so you had an array of
the entire history but the site is
making a pin art and not make 8-bit art
and replay it and it would be out of
character for me to build a monolith
suite of drawing and replaying tools
instead of having a separate app that
replayed the process info from my
drawing app and I decided that if I do
that I can then standardize that process
info in a way that it can be used in any
app that wanted in on the action whether
or not actually built it I want to
democratize the pixel and the process
this exploration of process in its place
in the open web ecosystem led to my
invention of picks on or Pixlr option
pixel art object notation and it doesn't
have to just be about pixel art it could
just be anything with pixels much like
how JSON is used outside of JavaScript
despite its name I might not write that
to her anymore but I always take a
chance to troll the daddy of JSON so
picks on is a proposed standard for the
representation the pics are using JSON
and properties of the exit rdf schema it
provides means for both lightweight data
interchange and the object oriented
creation of digital images especially
for pixel art I use JSON because of how
universal it is unlike past attempts at
anti compression formats like X bitmap
which were written in C and its sequel X
pixmap although this is like in the late
80s when the universe wasn't all that
big so Universal interchange was a
different kind of beast actually a
thought just crossed my mind that maybe
this will make a comeback with
webassembly
you know I [ __ ] love this format by
the way and it sort of inspired my
thinking of Brown representing animated
pixel art using pics on where you're
defining the colors as a variable and
then each like string is just like the
listing of the pixels by that color
which i think is pretty rad but ya pick
songs just JSON there are two objects
Exmouth and Pyxis
EXIF is any sort of properties defined
by the exchangeable image format rdf
schema which specifies the formats used
by digital devices like cameras and
scanners to tag digital images if you
look at the info of your photo it has
the info of like what you took the photo
with and you know when you think about
the app and software combo that you make
to draw pixel art is itself a digital
device and for the sake of Korean fits
art many of the properties are not
necessary or even affable applicable
I've narrowed it down to software
artists image description user comment
copyright in daytime but you can like
add as many things as you want I know it
J's copy you Ryan doll like one of his
regrets about node was how much
configuration is in package JSON I just
say like figure every [ __ ] thing and
package shape you can add as much as you
want to pics on but because it's based
on a schema that's existed since like
2003 before that pics if is the Pixar
it's been @exif in essence it's unique
to pixel images breaks down the image
beyond its typical metadata and focuses
on the individual strokes and drawings
of the pixels within the image
the first property pixels is an array of
pixel objects representing the pixels
drawn in the image so you basically push
to that array as the pixel is created
and you see those recognized with X Y
color coordinates it can or cannot be
immutable
I prefer immutable so that you're
constantly just pushing pixels so you
can see the whole process of drying you
know if you're a spy you can like write
a message and then erase it all and then
draw over it I love like spies seem cool
because it's a new idea in this format
the list of properties is fluid and
ever-changing at the moment so right now
it's just XY in color but it's a pretty
young standard considering how little
work I've been able to put into it since
I started I can see future Canon
properties and pics it like frames for
animated pixel art and it'll probably
look something quite like X bitmap
electric boogaloo and pixel objects can
also contain stroke IDs like they do and
make a bit
if you view the source I think Potch had
contributed that years ago I just
figured that as the community of people
developing what picks on grows and more
properties can be standardized and the
whole purpose of proposed in the
standard is so that everyone can use it
and build great apps on their own to
collaboratively and and build a
community of cool folks excited about
the open web and how it can be used to
continue innovating digital art I'm
lucky for me that's already been
happening in the past few years so I
wanted to give you a look at some of the
things that I've built and other people
have built in the past couple years that
import and export pick song so pick song
loop clip me is the original picks on
playground I built during my residency I
made in NY used to live in August dot
today and it's you drew it it has an
initial picks on file that draws that
message and you can export it you can
import picks on and play around with it
and it just loops drawing it over and
over again just want to show off that
glish apps have a console you can see
here that a the picks on file for that
drawing is only 14 kilobits and a PNG
file would probably be about like 50k
and a gif of high quality because you
want anti compression because pixel art
when it's compressed looks like garbage
the littlest if any compression would be
much higher so if you have a photograph
and you export it to pics on it's going
to be a really large JSON file you
probably just want to use the photograph
but if you're concerned about keeping
the process of creating abstract pixel
art pics on is much more performant make
8-bit art implements the ability to
import and export pics on it's not as
good as I'd liked it to be but I'm
planning to spend my open-source time in
q4 that's director speak for the fourth
quarter of the year to focus on tree
factory make a pit art so it doesn't use
jQuery I want to be more responsive so
it works as a PWA I got to add like a
manifest and all that fun stuff
and I want to enhance the pics on
experience cross-browser since there
tends to be issues image two picks on
glyph me converts her image to pics on I
made it on the fly because there's this
kid who is making a video game for his
final project in college and he had it
saved but then like his browser crashed
and localstorage for some reason cleared
out i implemented or just save your
artwork and he was like I need to import
this image so bad and I don't have that
part of me beep at art so I gave him
this evening for him to import the pics
on version of art and he did really want
less final which is really cool so even
though that's not really what the point
it picks on is like it's there you can
do it people do weird stuff with all
tech that we do anyway terror against
Allah made pixel eyes which is inspired
by the previous app and it lets you pick
flies or pixel ties the image before
converting to pics on which i think is
pretty rad
Blake Winton made an acorn extension if
maybe use the acorn image editing app
that lets you export your images to pics
on just search acorn pics on and you'll
find the gist come up Matthew Hudson
made an NPM module I haven't had a
chance to use yet it's fairly new he
emailed me he said pick songs available
can I like name my module that I was
like I'm not your mom you can name it
that but I don't think it's like the
right name for it but he Lee did it
anyway take me to church and then this
guy Annie made an SVG picks on renderer
which is really rad so it just takes
picks on and then converts it to SVG so
there are people who have made art make
8-bit art and they're like I want to
convert this to SVG and I'm like export
the pics on run it through this renderer
and you've got your SVG so I don't have
to build that monolith image editing app
I can have the set of like apps that I
list in the app for people to use and I
think you can just search SVG picks on
renderer on code pen and have it going
there and basically it just creates the
SVG element and just adds a little
pixels to it so yeah the future of pixel
is unknown it needs work I plan to
improve its usage
art and build more apps on glitch that
you all can remix and create the apps of
your dreams with and if you're
interested in getting involved the spec
can be read at Gen money dot biz slash
pics on of course I should probably get
its own official site who knows if you
want us to watch more of me talking
about pics on pixel art of computer
graphics in general I mean such a
prototype of pixel art process for
animation in my thgs
talk about the array prototype before I
had my residency it had rave reviews
much like he also loved my jorts art
talk I also then spoke at James comp
Columbia after my residency where I
launched pics on shortly after I
released the first draft yeah shout outs
in Columbia dev that's one of the best
conferences ever and I sort of
deconstructed the pixel and talked about
the things that I was working on back
then I was the only one that had been
doing anything that picks on and as you
can see in the past couple of years more
people have the communities growing
which is great I talked about some
computer graphics theory on specifically
how to use bresenhem's line algorithms
to draw lines and pixel grids at code
genius and some year yeah that that
crowd they think I look like Golding but
yeah that was that was a fun that's one
of my favorite talks
despite the comments so yeah yeah in
2014 I authored an algorithm ingest and
shortly after I authored the original
spec for picks on not not ingests this
isn't a joke and I think that anyone can
and should do that kind of stuff and the
great thing about tech is that much of
its history has been documented and we
could take that and run with it and then
our own technologies and help people
make great things and just like how
there's always a new framework in our
ecosystem that makes development easier
for us the evolution of all technology
needs us to have room to explore an
invent you know like remember how like
those prestigious research institutions
like JPL and Xerox PARC and Bell Labs
they needed help from artists and
computer scientists who had a passion
for art and they needed them to drive
innovation so we can see pixels on a
screen today and I feel
like I could already feel see it
happening already that history is
repeating itself and we're gonna need
artists and web developers and computer
scientists interested in art to drive
how future pixels are shown and I think
it's imperative that more women need to
be given a space and credit for that
exploration so I dedicate this talk to
Joe Miller who in 1969 in Bell Labs
pioneered paint software by creating the
first frame buffer that was three bit
you can't really find much info on Joan
and when they talk about the frame
buffer they're like yeah it's the first
but it was pretty slow it was 1969 like
everything was slow so yeah not
surprisingly homegirl doesn't have a
Wikipedia page and hopefully that will
change anyway I hope you all enjoy the
rest of this incredible conference I
think I earned this if you have
questions about pics on or glitch please
do email me or come up to me throughout
the day I really want to talk to y'all
and see what kind of cool stuff that
you're making and yeah thank you very
much
you